Well tangible has. A why of screening. People i guess you'd say. That is that.
Anybody that wants to move on to that community has to meet. To try and and just gossip briefly.
And then it's up to the tribe. And the hamlet that you're actually moving on to.
So when are you drawn to the hamlet of. I had to meet all the managers and talk with them.
It was a safety mechanism for me because i could soon sauce out but i wasn't living next door to a shotgun. And.
They could sauce out the dollars a peace loving hippie tart. To say it was a great safety valve. And then for bonding.
It's a matter of having to rent there first for twelve months and.
I feel that's really cool and i'm sure that's why the families are so contented and.
Don't have to carry a great deal of defense around with them.
My house or collars like i think ninety eight percent of the houses on timetable. It doesn't have a lock.
And i've never had any trouble with people using the house. If you walking by people not used to dani.
But there's certainly not in your living room or having cups of tea
or stealing things i've had a lot of travel with my modified. House it's quite on the off. That it's. Yes.
Most of the house is a set back into a rainforest and so they're very private and all that
and i visit quite close we can actually save them.
If i was to yell off madhur and i might hear me
and i can certainly hear one of my knives singing often implying the guitar. Fortunately has a good voice and.
Plays guitar well. But yes rain forest. It becomes quite a leap in the wet season.
And we have about eight or twelve weeks of that. Each year and. So they can get a bit muddy under thought.
Rain boot country. But for the rest of the it's very beautiful and. We have many trees from all over the world and.
Coffees ground there and. Lots of exotic plants that.
You don't see in many places other than the potential garden and it is this love for the earth.
That people have brought back. Things from other countries and grown up there and it's fantastic.
Yes we have a tribal council which is very similar to any council that. Looks after a body of people. And the tribe.
Insists that there's no real profit making on real estate there. The house that i mean. Has a set price and.
The only couldn't put upon herself that it was worth twenty thousand more because you know.
Neighbors' houses are worth twenty thousand or more if it hasn't gone up with the rest of inflation.
And so the average house there would be about twenty ten to twenty thousand dollars which is very realistic.
In this neighborhood because if you're looking at a few acres on your own with a constable do well
when you might be looking at seventy or eighty thousand dollars.
So it makes it very realistic for young parents to move on and to. Want to start having children.
Because they haven't got that. Huge mold each to have to worry about or tend to.
And it means to a lot more time spent with.
The children and i think that's why the kids are walking around quite contented they do see a lot of dad
and they do see a lot of mom. And it's cry. That says. Oh yes there is a shared to share system.
And to buy shares the intangible share costs five hundred dollars still and.
I'm sure that's been a stable price now for ten.
Ten years or fifteen years
or even the whole existence of it is most probably doing something very realistic life that you see.
It's just a question. It's a question. So. My views on poverty. As such happiness and joy and.
I see a lot of happiness there. And i don't see a lot of new commodores or. Shiny lawnmowers that you see it on.
And i guess. Values are looked upon as slightly different than how they might be looked upon in a city where the news.
Is certainly a value on tangible.
I guess we'll fortunate to have two all four wheels that are still managing to get across the roads.
To get the kids off to high school or. To get around to do the shopping.
But the commune itself is actually very good it has its own vast vast shelter and.
That's set up for people that haven't got cars for the single moms that i have cause for the kids that just want to go
to newman and apply on opinion or whatever they consider the bus shelter. And as.
As a driver myself when i drive past the vast older his ever sitting there it's like a cabaret.
If it was this is the first one on my motorbike or if i have room for three in my car.
It can fit the first three in and.
I've never seen people drive past me
when i want to go to town if it's pouring rain i don't want to sit on my motorbike. I sit in the bus shelter and.
The first car that goes possibly the car that picks me up.
And i really like that aspect and life was for the return journey from them than to tangible. Isn't a problem.
First lift all over town. Yet. On tangible people. Their food. And is a lot of food grown men air.
And it is massive orchards there to make massive sums of money.
They're there for people to pick the man drains or the pages.
When they're riding past on their horse or walking past on. Force. And i like that idea and.
I don't think i've ever left and without holding onto the caney apartheid. Or something.
And it's usually a little bag of. Vegetables which is fantastic. Oh yes i guess. My favorite story.
For tangible would be ok. You have one of the best times for me.
Time to vote was when i took my mother out there with my niece and nephew and.
They spent the day there and we walked all over the commune and saw. Most probably one hundred houses and.
Welling's where people live. And when we were leaving. Dawn who is quite middle class and quite sydney.
Said to my niece and nephew i bet you didn't expect when we drove into this valley to meet so many interesting people.
To see so many beautiful dwellings and. I think that was a wonderful story because.
Dorn had never seen anything like that before. And she fell in love with it.
And i thought that was very very good because there is no curbing gathering
and there are no electricity power poles running along. And that. One can feel i only invaded.
Without those things i guess.
After living with them for sixty surfer do want to feel very comfortable there immediately.
And to get the vibe of the place immediately. I thought was a wonderful thing. Perth.
Godly eccentricities to call those people that. I think most people see themselves as doing what they want to do.
One of their childhood dreams one of their adult dreams. They cannot leave it there. And it's not at a great cost.
Like the dream about one hundred foot yacht of all.
The mansion on the hill can often be very frustrating graeme because you spend a lifetime trying to get to that.
And a tangible that's more realistic. So people can. Out and.
They can live their dream they can bring their children math.
Or in my case they can walk around feeling very comfortable being who i am and.
I think that's good to have such a neighborhood on the planet.
And yes i think people intangible do have a very high level of tolerance and that's go right. I'm sure at the end of.
People go outside the guidelines if that.
If they have not if they're having problems within their domestic life
or within the night the law if it's very common i think on the outside.
To just call the police or to clean coal and inspect durrell to get the outside to actually piii and. To work out.
The decision making. I find it time to pull a lot of it's. Have to leave and worked out with dean and.
I've only seen success stories through it.
And yes it must be very frustrating while those people are in such a dilemma.
But i certainly have the time to post a video with it and give it. The time to post the view. And. Yeah.
Saying that it's cool to think you know if it's true.
It's actually not but of course we markus it doesn't really run you probably not for us. Ok.
All right mark jackson then i moved to mumbai.
Just because it seemed like a nice thing to do for awakened at the time and. There was.
Rod savella with the supplies truck that was put in bringing supplies down to the crew who were making the preparations
for the festival and.
About two and a half months before the first we were kind to waken than twenty years down the track i'm still here.
It was really just a nice thing to do for wake in the you know nost trip to the countryside and.
I guess i just fell in love with the environment around. Nimbin and.
We used to come down the back road through the known by valley so that.
Even on the trip down you know it was like going through a problem a whole jungle compared to what i was used to
brisbane. Being a bit of a concrete jungle. So i was a complete contrast and.
I think it was really a matter of falling in love with the environment really that.
And i mean joy coming and caused me to stay i think i was probably you know ten or fifteen years before that.
The two most thought of living in philly dick and lost all
and i think it had a lot to do with the fact that i saw that. I was living in tents lead to couldn't.
Civilization is a means of production and was sort of by stone on its own demise and.
I think the concept in the future which was that the concept that. The punk generation sort of. Brought to light.
Was you know a strong perception in a lot of the time so it basically you know working in a mental hospital and.
Drinking a lot and. Doing various other bad things to my body and.
Moving to newman was just like getting back in contact with life you know sort of being connected with night.
And looking at how useless i was a realisation that i'd been trying to be someone i sits at a desk
or does something similar to that and had no life skills whatever interns of. You know. Cooking. Building. You know.
Doing anything that was immediately useful in the survival sense. Well it was a.
Really the aquarius festival as such and in fact.
By the time of the aquarius festival which is about three months after i arrived in nimbin.
I didn't bother to go to the festival because by then i was living in a house that sot of town
and was sort of in love with survival last stalls and the back tonight show movement that.
Of us that we couldn't be bothered going to town to celebrate that.
You know i was just quietly celebrating valma self the fact that i was living in the countryside.
It was really a process of becoming involved in all of the price is that my cloth possible
and trying to get involved with them in a you know holistic way i saw that. You know.
Recognizing that are new to a child become involved in growing vegetables in burying shit cans in cooking and.
You know that whole process. And you know applying that.
That sort of holistic involvement with prices across all the areas of my life and. Probably in particular.
Becoming involved in the tray so i call. If you like and.
You know that the first contact thing wanting to make a musical instrument.
A god that i knew and this is probably six months after the fistula so i was making dulcimers which are four string.
Musical instruments from the appalachian mountains making mine obviously involve getting some woodworking tools in
among the wood waiting tools that are the border was given was a chinese saw that i was given by the guy called sam
across and the sawmill at the kind of all falls. Co-operative property before it was the total cop.
He gave me a chance or and i was building a house by this time and.
The guy who cleared the building saw it with his bulldozer. Offered me a job blogging and.
Because i was building a timber house
and various other reasons i thought that it was probably the fair thing to take the logan job so i did that industry
for about two years and having been involved in cutting a lot of trees down i thought that i should plant some.
What would have suited me at the time was to work for the government.
You know toward rights of pipe time and get a bit more than a dollar and have the rest of the time frame
but because there was nothing happening on those lawns i saw the radar station contracting business.
By the tossing through the local newspapers and found that there was a very substantial demand from people who wanted.
Trays planted on their way and. You were planted.
The five thousand trays for you know a hundred different landowners over the next five years. And until that.
Business was cleaned up in the recession.
You ninety three at which time i had a bad back chronic tin ear and about five thousand dollars worth of debts and
when up to brisbane
and worked in a box for a couple of years to get myself back on with a building the house was quite an experience
because we did it in. Nine seventy four which was the you know the biggest. Flood that we've had in in recent times.
And so it did run through fairly solidly for about five months.
But it was a great experience you know sort of picking up building skills as. As you go along.
Using the materials that kind of and like the whole house cost. Over the order of a thousand dollars to get.
You know the basic house structure up. So that.
For example we have products in the house were split added trays on the property and then brought extra nads to.
You know. Provide a sort of thought by five. Refuse and. You know lots of second hand materials for.
So i call materials and it turned out quite a beautiful structure and.
Well while we didn't have any of accolades that time and. It's good for about.
I think fifteen years and had one child born in a blasted well and. You know gave a lot of people.
Shelter and satisfaction with it and i think. Nimbin was the thought because for all sorts of alternative ideas.
And a lot of those ideas have now been co-opted into mind strange society either. You know.
Fifteen twenty years ago if you write brown rice and so on you are some kind of fruit cake
and now you could be the prime minister. A lot of the ideas that were looked on as.
You know sort of wild and fanciful then.
As i said now mind stream and environmental concern has set me in that category of thought is that where espoused.
Strongly they. That are now at the consent of everyone.
So i think that as a focus for alternative hardy as it said they played a substantial role in the environment movement.
Also either the sun and been a lot of my gains in terms of forest issues not necessarily by people at nimbin
but by people who are. You know. Among the alternative lifestyle community on the north coast and probably.
Notably the community had to run a craig.
The secession of rainforest logging in new south wales was largely a result of that protest and the subsequent protest.
Matt not be against blogging in the not cat national what's now the not cat national park out there and.
I was actually arrested there. On the the die before the.
The decision was taken to stop writing for us logging in new south wales or.
A decision that purported to stop rainforest logging in new south wales was taken. But i have to that.
It's probably the one thing that needs to be said is that there are a great party.
Yeah i think everyone is kind to the protests were all there was a lot of great about what was happening in the forests
there was a lot of joy in coming together and working for a common cause
and it's certainly a very positive experience i think for everyone who attended the protestant clued in probably some
of the place and. And maybe even some of the longer this you know i think that perhaps even the end of it.
You know there was great things going on. You know sweat lodges and. You know. Campfires and.
Lots of music and lots of message and. You know there was a strong festival omen.
To all of the forest protests that are saying. Very well thanks i certainly concerned about the environment.
Is the thing that runs through all of the alternative ideas.
And you know the idea that way by sickly part of night sure and made.
To moderate amount to moderate out the mines on natural systems and. Live in harmony with nature is you know.
One of the key concepts in the whole alternative movement. That's that n.c.d.c. Christian. It's becoming very.
You know this. A reorientation of priorities the. Comes from moving from the city to the country and.
The idea of becoming more involved in the process is that mike you are. Possible.
I think you know it involves a fundamental shift in values.
Having said that there are men just by coming to value natural processes and.
Trying to become involved in the trial processes in a holistic y.
Doesn't mean that you suddenly cut yourself off from your past and.
People often expect that people are moved to the country necessarily stoppel the habits that they had
when they were living in the city. And that.
That certainly isn't the case i think so has been a dialectic and i between hope
and despair us by as you know despair being the paradigm that it's dominant in. You know sort of poor urban lost all.
And there's a fair bit of despair in a poor rural lost all outside suit but at least. Runs.
You know in intimate contact with night here and the forces of life.
So that i think i spend a lot of time between then and now. Sort of you know poised between hope and despair.
I mean there's still a lot of strong indications that the human rights is down the tubes and.
In the next century or two into ends of climatic disruption the greenhouse effect the eyes on the place and.
All of those sorts of problems. If they're not addressed obviously not very favorable to the survival of s. Bases.
And i think that it's. It's very important that alternatives to. You know the current. Consumer oriented.
Last also put forward. And i think that's part of the real value of now and then. Well i think.
There was a reasonable component of the fed newsom.
Although made him much of the activity that passes for head news and actually creates a pleasure. You know.
In in our the short medium or long to them is probably questionable. But i think a lot of.
What some people would say is they had an ism. That's a lot. You know and.
A lot of what passes for hidden ism is really about a skype ing from painful realities.
And those realities if you try to skype from the intended just become more painful. Another image of chinese in nimbin.
Since i want to set those windows so they're going to be a problem with a magic change in nimbin that i've seen since
nine seventy three.
And actually could you know how to fairly definite song about three four years after the festival was the arrival of
smacking newman. You know.
Prior to that there was virtually no straight crime you'd leave the case
and you can have no concerns about the security behind and so on and. You know as soon as. Drugs are often in bin or.
You know. Visibly iraq to nimbin. That all chinese to and.
You know on a certain level applies has been going downhill since then.
You know in terms of social amenity and so on and i think that that's probably a function of.
Polarity between hope and despair. You know that has caused.
Going to give
and some of the alternative ideas that have come forward in their adoption by mindstream says saudi there's also
considerable grounds for despair and. Individuals you know i caught between those two poles can go either way.
And i think the name in his applies would buy i think stranger hardly visible you know where you've got some of the
most constructive alternatives interns of. You know environmental work in terms of alternative technologies.
You've also got a substantial number of people who live through. Bicycling concerned with. Walking themselves out and.
Newman seems to be apply self extremes you know.
One of the things that i used to side bet nimbin is that it was a very tolerant place in fact it was.
The town where even intelligence was tolerated and. Yeah. It's certainly applies to. Visible extremities.
Of a number of different spectrums.
There was a few reasons why i left new even one was that i wanted to study at university and.
You know get more actual skills in middle management.
And so i was much more convenient given that the university it was in was more. To move in lismore.
But also newman is quite a small community
and it can be quite difficult living in a small community in terms of their very own eyes what everyone else was doing
all the time and.
You know you use a certain amount of anonymity is always quite good to have in your life so i think part of a larger
community is as. As i am in lismore as is another of the reasons why i left the us.
I think the main thing that put strains on relationships. At nimbin is the fact that there's very little work and.
Consequently very little income inside of building a house and rising children. When you're on the dollar.
It is basically extremely difficult and.
You know you might tell your allies and ships in those extremely difficult economic circumstances.
Is is not an easy task. So that.
While i was running the trade planning business i was probably earning less than it would have been getting on the
dollar. So you know just. That many years of. Of that level of poverty.
I think that places great strides on relationships and so they do it online. No nothing i've written him in story.
Of cup with i've written him and nine. Sin bin and it's on family and show you coming to the places.
And been extremely important in a strained society i do remember growing dunston signing to me once that.
Kanaan in thirty or thirty nine the place for a young man of goodwill was in spine.
And on in seventy three it was in still tend to believe that the truth and that. And that and.
As a focus for alternative ideas that newman supplied a very important role in history and society.
I think like the rest of us struggle with nim in his you know my dad significant gains in terms of the natural
environment through.
Reestablishing trade cover and so on but in terms of whether it's done and offered side differently. And you know.
The newman valley is probably one of the best areas in a strategy for growing trays and.
While the significant numbers being planted i think we need to get.
Applied work force and commercially driven trade growing activities and.
And we also made an acceptance across the saudi that the environmental cost of development always need to be balanced
by environmental benefits. To counterbalance those costs.
Well i think it's not just a challenge for new minutes the challenge for australia to realise that we are the get
sustainable or we're on the last.
Humans always been a magnet for fruitcakes of various kinds you know other people who just you know because their ideas
were too progressive or too good food mindstream society of tended to guy the people whose ideas
and behavior were unacceptable to the rest of society who tended to gather this and. You know there's been some.
Contested. Is that have been born there has been some wondering incredibles that you wouldn't believe a pleasure.